z
isn't that the first thing you think of
when you hear that title i'm kidding i
just love the title of the movie
the second you hear it you go the z must
stand for
zombies and then you think of the
concept of a zombie
apocalypse and you go holy [ __ ]
this movie's gonna be awesome just
hearing about it
then you watch the trailer and some
concerns kick in let's start off
with brad pitt not that this affects the
movie but the man starting to look his
age
sure he's still better looking than me
but i got news for you brad pitt
you're getting old let's talk about his
performance
this movie has such a huge hollywood
high concept plot about humanity coming
to an end but surprisingly
brad pitt is kind of nonchalant he's
just very
calm sure he looks concerned but seems
to lack a certain level of intensity who
knows
maybe when i watch the actual movie
it'll be a subtle performance
as for the movie itself it doesn't feel
like a zombie movie it feels like a
zombie apocalypse the vibe i get is not
so much
like dawn of the dead or 28 days later
with the cg of the monsters in this
movie and the way they move
it reminds me more of will smith's i am
legend and a crossover of steven
spielberg's war of the worlds because
similar to war of the worlds it's about
an apocalypse the center of the film
is about a father trying to protect his
family which is a great choice for the
story because it helps keep everything
more personal
see what i gathered from this world war
z trailer was that it doesn't sacrifice
character for thrills
because the better the characters the
better the thrills i do have to say
one of my main issues that i saw in this
trailer was the zombies themselves
they don't look scary they look too cg
part of what makes a zombie film so
great
is great realistic zombie effects but
when the zombies look
this fake it's difficult to feel that
fear
because the effects can pull you out of
the movie my last concern is the film's
director mark forster
he's made some great films in the past
such as finding neverland
and monsters ball that's my nickname but
lately he's brought us
machine gun preacher and let's not
forget that big piece of [ __ ]
quantum of solace world war z looks
better than those movies
and hopefully it is but i'm still not
over how shitty quantum of solace was
but i do have a feeling that mark
forster may have been able to find that
perfect blend
of emotional depth backed up with high
concept thrills
so with all concerns aside i feel like
the storytelling will be better than the
zombie effects
and to me that's what matters most
regardless there are fantastic money
shots in this trailer
it looks like no matter what fault it
has it'll deliver on entertainment
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say world war z
could get it right
all right guys thanks for checking out
the video please go ahead scroll to that
comment box and tell me your points
below
and if you hate the video you can go
[ __ ] yourself
and if you want to check out more of my
reviews or if you want to get updated
every time a new review is out
go ahead and subscribe to my channel
you